the number of confirmed coronavirus
cases worldwide has passed
40 million with well over a million
deaths
the u.s brazil and india are reporting
the highest numbers
europe is also facing a surge in covid19
infections with
record daily highs in many countries let
me give you a quick overview of
how the situation has developed on march
1st of this year
health departments across europe
registered 401
new cases keep in mind testing was not
as widespread as now so
actual numbers could have been much
higher but you can see a clear trend of
rising daily infections uh
peaking at the end of april beginning of
may at
by by then most of europe was in
lockdown and you can see the effect of
that here with a new
uh infections dropping to a low point in
mid-july but since then
the numbers have been creeping up again
with new cases rising steadily since
august on friday more than 137
000 daily cases were registered
across europe well one of the european
countries struggling to cope with the
pandemic is
belgium hospitals emissions of korean
virus patients there
have doubled in the past week and the
government is warning
the situation is worse than at the
beginning of the pandemic in march
there were long queues in brussels on
monday people lined up
socially distanced to get tested for
coronavirus
belgium has recorded more than 700
infections per 100
000 people over the past 14 days the
second highest rate in europe
many have had their first brush with the
virus and now they want to be sure that
they're not infected
someone close to me tested positive so i
want to get tested to be sure
i don't have any symptoms but better to
be safe than sorry
with such a high rate of infection
belgium authorities implemented a raft
of new measures on monday
people have been ordered to work from
home wherever possible
and social contacts outside of the home
should be limited to one
alcohol sales are banned after 8 pm and
a curfew is being enforced from midnight
until 5 a.m cafes bars and restaurants
will be closed for a month
many hospitality workers are frustrated
with the return to some of the harsh
measures
experienced earlier in the year it's
like the first time
it's catastrophic we will just have to
try and survive
we've had some state aid and that's
something
it's better than nothing but we'll see
but belgian officials say the measures
are absolutely necessary
the country's health minister says the
health system could soon be overwhelmed
by infections
and warned of a coming tsunami of cases
many doctors share his concerns
the sky is more or less blue but we can
see a huge wave is about to arrive
it's inevitable authorities hope the
drastic set of measures will
have a quick impact they say they'll
review the results
in two weeks time
france has reported a massive increase
in the number of people
hospitalized with covet 19 over 2000 are
currently in intensive care
that's the highest number since may and
it's putting health
services under considerable strain
authorities have imposed a partial
curfew in paris and
eight other cities as one of multiple
measures aimed at stemming the virus
the curfew affects some 20 million
people and is set to last at least four
weeks
authorities also made face masks
compulsory
outside the home
well for more let's cross over to dw's
paris correspondent lisa
lewis lisa is there any indication that
these
new measures to curb infections are
actually working
well i think it's a bit early for that
the curfew in these cities
came into force on saturday and you know
when you look back
at you know the past 24 hours there have
indeed only been
30 13 000 new infections compared to
about
32 000 just a few days back but that's
basically
down to labs being closed on sunday and
if you look at intensive care units as
you just said
that's a new high since may and also
covert 19 related deaths have climbed to
146
compared to just 1890 a few days ago
within 24 hours here so it's getting
more dire indeed
how are people in france coping with
these
new restrictions lisa
well it is a bit difficult and there is
quite
a backlash uh especially by those that
will be economically impacted by
the new measures for example restaurant
and bar owners
those who manage theaters and cinemas
they're saying the bulk of our business
is taking place
at night and we will really lose out
government is putting
another billion euros on the table to
help those people
but you know when it comes to
restaurants hotels and buyers for
example i've been told
that 30 percent of all uh those
uh establishments will actually enter
bankruptcy proceedings
already so it is very difficult for them
they're obviously saying you know we
should the government should create
exceptions for us letters for example
people
have eid have dinner at eight o'clock so
that they can go back
at 10 and that will mainta won't make
any difference actually will only you
know to the infection rate
it will only make a difference to our
business because
it will mean that we will be able to
survive this crisis
now enacting new anti-corona measures is
one thing and
forcing them quite another how tough are
authorities being
when it comes to enforcement
well the police has already done about
twenty thousand controls over the past
few days since saturday when the curfew
came
into force three thousand fines have
been handed down
about i think that is still and not that
high a figure the police has been told
to be but lenient with people in the
first few days
and you know it will take some time to
get used to these measures when i took
the metro last night at half past eight
it was packed and it normally isn't
packed at that time i think many people
were struggling to get home i got home
at 20 53
but lots of them lots of those with me
on the metro will would certainly didn't
get home by nine o'clock and i
understand the police
is in the first few days has been rather
lenient if you get home
at 10 past 15 past at nine so that
people can still get used to that new
measures
and actually adapt their schedule to to
it actually and be home by nine adapting
to that
pretty tough uh dw's lisa lewis in paris
thanks
well here's a look at some other
developments in the coronavirus pandemic
the
world health organization has linked
rising case numbers in the northern
hemisphere to
a failure to quarantine people exposed
to the virus
it's called for more consistency in
enforcing self-isolation measures
india has posted its lowest number of
daily cases in nearly three months
infections have been decreasing since a
peak in september
and hundreds of fishermen who flew into
new zealand to crew local vessels are
isolating in the city of christchurch
after 11 tested positive for the virus
new zealand had gone three weeks with no
community transmission of the illness
another victim of the global pandemic
has been press freedom
journalists have been harassed and
arrested for reporting on the spread of
the virus
some governments have introduced laws
punishing those who share information
that doesn't support the official line
muzzling the press can also endanger
public health
behind the mask of coronavirus
censorship spreads
journalists around the world have come
under attack for reporting on the
pandemic
it started in china where citizen
journalists dared to deviate from the
official narrative
chang shed images of overstretched
hospitals in wuhan
the virus is right in front of me
china's criminal prosecutors are behind
me
i'm not afraid of death do you think i'm
afraid of you communist party of china
disappeared in february and was only
seen again by friends in september
feng bin another reporter remains
missing
he had released secret videos of
coronavirus victims
reporters without borders has documented
coronavirus coverage restrictions in
nearly half of all u.n member states
those who are jailed are at risk of
infection
al al-jazeera journalist mohammed monir
died in july from coronavirus after
being arrested in egypt
as did reporter saleh al-shay jailed for
documenting corruption in saudi arabia
the deliberate targeting of the press
has worried the united nations human
rights commissioner
across the world covet 19 is also being
instrumentalized to limit people's
rights to speak to express opinion
and to participate in making decisions
that affect their lives
in the russian federation china kosovo
nicaragua and many other countries
i note reports of threats and
intimidation against journalists
bloggers and civic activists
particularly at the local level with the
apparent aim of discouraging criticism
of the authorities responses to covet
19.
at a time when information can save
lives
press repression can fuel the pandemic
let's bring in cedric alviani here he's
the east asia bureau head of reporters
without borders and joins us from
taipei thanks for being with us first of
all journalists are being attacked by
both
governments and demonstrators for
reporting on the korean virus has
your organization ever documented
anything like on this scale before
absolutely and in this period of
pandemic it has never been more vital
for the public to receive accurate
information
no matter where they are in the
world it's
somehow the proof that censorship is not
only the problem of the countries in
where it applies but it's a global
problem that democracies
have to tackle globally because it is a
fact that
if journalists had been able to provide
the alert
in china the virus probably would
have been addressed much earlier and
would have
left the chinese voters what impact
are these attacks on press freedom
having on
public awareness about the pandemic
in uh the case of china uh the uh
government has been every
very active at uh ousting foreign
journalists there have been
not less than 18 journalists
for brain correspondents uh experts are
forced to leave china since the
beginning of the year
there has also been a wave of arrests in
china
uh after a quick burst of free
expression because the chinese public
was so
upset when they realized the authorities
had been lying and had been covering up
the phenomenon that uh for a moment uh
they uh
there was a lot of peace preach like the
free free expression
uh was released online but there have
been a lot of
arrests and we can't at least uh
uh seven or eight journalists still
detained
in china today so mr albiani
what do you think can be done about this
how can
press freedom be defended in countries
where it's being attacked so severely in
this pandemic
well the
example of china that had an
exemplary management of the kovi 19
crisis
without going against any principle of
the rule of law
shows that an auto
treatment of the pandemic does not bring
any
positive effect actually it is even very
dangerous
you can uh not pretend that the virus is
not there
is going to come back and remind you
there
so it's extremely important that uh the
public could access
accurate information on the virus on its
effects
on the way to protect themselves also
because without this
the public might get uh leave
some uh illegitimate contents and might
take the wrong decisions which uh could
could bring the
pandemics to an even worse level cedric
alviani
of reporters without borders thank you
very much
berlin is famous for its nightlife
especially the club scene here
it all came to a grinding halt though
earlier this year due to the coronavirus
pandemic
nightclubs remain closed and now the
city government has tried to impose an
11 pm
closing time on all bars and restaurants
some bar owners have
gone to court and won so they're allowed
to remain
open for now we've been out about to see
what's happening
to the party metropolis berlin
berlin once europe's nightlife capital
has quietened down since the beginning
of the pandemic
doors are closed dance floors empty
clubbers are not the only ones affected
owners
face a whole winter without business
many believe the city's cultural
landscape
will be the poorer
unscripted for us there are two
priorities during this pandemic
first save people second save club
culture
if you've experienced what it's like to
dance together to amazing music
to feel free and safe within a friendly
crowd
berlin is known as a haven for artists
and musicians in particular
they've been especially hard hit
professionally and in their everyday
lives
as an artist and event manager a lot
changed
this situation never as i've never seen
before
the measures have put a damper on
socializing in the capital
and they're a big challenge for
restaurant and bar owners
they fear limits on opening times and
alcohol sales
will threaten their livelihoods once
again
escaped there are some things that we as
a hospitality branch find absolutely
necessary
social distancing wearing a mask those
are really good measures and so is
making sure bars are not crowded
what we don't understand is why for
months the gastronomy and nightlife
sector has been saddled with all the
blame
we've been treated as culprits and
that's not the case
customers too have had to adapt some
though willing to make sacrifices find
the measures perplexing
i had to think about what i was about to
do
more but i don't think it changed the
number of people i saw
and in this sense i don't know if these
measures was
so efficient now like that you're like
inside your house with your close
friends like
it changed a lot so you get to know the
people better
and you get to spend much more time with
these people
for safety's sake most people have
accepted the restrictions on their
social lives with grace
but many do wonder whether berlin will
ever be the same
again
you